j'ai besoin que même les personnes et le
retard ce que j'espère c'est que
j'attende qui pourrait me dire qui je
suis et j'ai bien peur toute ma vie
d'être incompris car aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas
je suis
des gens
ce pas
mais ont-ils cherché à savoir d'où
venait me
mes joies mes
ce thé
perché fond de moi
si des apparences sont quelques fois
contre moi je ne suis pas ceux que l'on
croit
contre l' aventure deux chats
ce jour je changerais
la joie d'un seul amour mais je suis là
je suis
elle aimait
connaissent pas que jamais
andré mais ont-ils cherché à savoir
mes joueurs mais
pourquoi ce désespoir caché au fond de
moi
car je suis
mal aimé je suis là
jean me gomez 2
mais
attention
chercher
mais
et
ce désespoir cacher
de moi car je suis
laid
les gens me connaissent
celle que j'avais
de semer
cherchez pas droit
cachés au fond de moi oui je veux pas
ad mais je suis le mal aimé lui les gens
me connaissent d'elle que je veux
montrer mais on il cherchait à savoir
d'où me vient de mes joies et pourquoi
ce désespoir caché au fond de moi oui je
suis
mais je suis
mal aimé je suis le mal aimé
je suis là
je suis
mallet
merci
ma
gens me connaissent
que je veux me montrer
ont-ils cherché à savoir
tout va bien
mais joie
pourquoi ce d'espoir gachet
débrouille bien dans les champs sans mal
je suis mal aimé
les gens
je veux
ont-ils cherché à savoir d'où me vient
choix et pourquoi se disent moi caché au
fond de moi
au fond de nous quelle merveilleuse
chanson de la chambre remplie ce d'une
façon absolument se trouve très haut
perché oui je fais les coeurs la juge un
vieux d'obama et je vais mettre à l'aise
quand même parce que tu as une chemise
et moi j'ai l'impression
il faut se mettre au diapason de ses
invités magnifique